[Music]
you have no idea do you what did you
choose not to know your husband stole
three million dollars for me
[Music]
this is about my life
[Music]
this is above my [ __ ]
because it's about my life and that
becomes about yours
so don't happen to make something better
mr. Mulligan your family's been involved
in Harry's life for many years I need
help I don't see what I can do
our husbands aren't coming back
Ronna my husband left me the plans for
his next job
all I need is a cool to pull it off why
should we trust you anyway because I'm
the one standing between you and a
bullet in your head
[Music]
that's what I've learned from then let
your late husband and my father that you
reap what you sow let's hope so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is for guns guns from where figure
it out
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it
I did something
[Music]
but the best thing we have going for is
is being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off
[Music]
[Music]